la basura es un problema con muchísimos
intereses
pero con muy pocos interesados en
resolver el problema
pero la basura dice todo y nosotros
imagínese en ustedes que yo puedo saber
cuántos miembros ocupan su casa
simplemente por la cantidad de residuos
que produce
puedo saber que también se alimentan
porque los residuos salen las cáscaras y
los empaques de los alimentos consumidos
yo puedo saber cosas íntimas como por
ejemplo si hay un adicto en su familia
porque los residuos salen las pruebas de
lo que consuma
yo puedo saber si hay un enfermo
inclusive hasta de que porque en los
residuos salen los en paquetes las
drogas consumidas
en nombre de jhon ramírez tengo 53 años
soy el reciclador de oficio y hago parte
de la fundación del bolero una
organización de recicladores de base que
construye una alternativa de desarrollo
social y ambiental autosostenible a
partir
del manejo responsable de los residuos
sólidos y les voy a contar esta anécdota
una empresa nos contrata para que le
hagamos un diagnóstico de la producción
de residuos
en un diagnóstico nosotros lo que
hacemos es medir toda la producción de
residuos que tiene una empresa y ahí
hacemos una clasificación de los
residuos
entonces en esta empresa nos dimos
cuenta que salían muchos paquetitos de
snacks
entonces nos dimos a la tarea de
contarlos en cinco días
contamos diez mil 172 papelitos que
dividiendo los
en el número de empleados de esa empresa
que eran 650
nos da un poco más de 3 paqueticos por
persona al día como hay unos que no
comen paqueticos habían unos que estaban
comiendo 4 y 5 diarios lo que quiere
decir que están picando si están picando
es porque están ansiosos y si están
ansiosos es porque están estresados
conclusión hay un problema de estrés en
la empresa
los residuos no mienten
pero dejamos saber que nos cuentan los
decididos
es que esto es esto es cuestión de
pandero no es
esto es fácil sí porque es que
[Música]
es que los residuos realmente
con una radiografía de la de la sociedad
y tiene que ver con mucho con todos
nuestros hábitos toda nuestra vida yo
les cuento la verdad
yo estas bolsas las aquí así de aquí en
la universidad y yo no sé que hay en la
verdad no sé tal como lanza que la
basura quise traer la cara
porque es que la cuestión es qué
que podemos ver
en un inicio
si están esta bolsita prácticamente esto
es lo que producimos en todas partes
sí
primeramente podemos ver que acá no hay
una selección en la fuente ya podemos
decir por ejemplo digamos que
faltan una cantidad de cosas digamos
para que esto pudiera ser aprovechado
digamos que la mayor parte
de los residuos que hay aquí son
recuperables sí pero por ejemplo podemos
ver todo este tipo de residuos sí que
nos dicen por ejemplo todos estos tipos
de residuos digamos que hay cualquier
cantidad de consumo de azúcar
pues para nadie es un secreto que el
azúcar es digamos como una de las
culpables de la mayor cantidad de
enfermedades
en los seres humanos
aquí prácticamente lo podemos ver si
esto es un consumo digamos de la
universidad
y eso que aquí la gente es inteligente
entonces
lo que quiero decirles es que todo lo
que hagamos se refleja
en los residuos esto así revuelto qué
pasa con esto
esto sencillamente va a contaminar el
ambiente
al contaminar el ambiente qué pasa
cuando el ambiente no es bueno para
nuestra salud tampoco
entonces la relación que tiene la
producción de residuos con la salud
es indisoluble
así es sencillo pero también podríamos
decir como la mayor parte de estos
residuos son recuperables es materia
prima
nosotros simplemente entendamos
ha de enterrar esta materia prima pues
lógicamente los recursos naturales se
agotan y por ende también nuestra salud
entonces
es muy importante digamos que hacer una
verdadera selección
para mejorar nuestra salud
que nos diría por ejemplo la basura de
su casa de ustedes
fíjese muy bien en lo que votan
para que comiencen a generar conciencia
de lo que consume
y aquí uno se da cuenta realmente aquí
podemos ver por ejemplo cómo será la
salud en años futuros de las personas
que consumen esto
esta basura no ambiente la basura lo
hice todo por eso este es un tema que
merece ser reciclado
[Aplausos]